so disney
is moving 2000 jobs from california to
florida here's why
one of the great things about america's
50th state federal system is that people
can vote with their feet in response to
different policies the walt disney
company is the latest business to plan
to move some operations out of
california in favor of a lower
tax state disney will move 2 000 jobs
from its california headquarters to a
new campus in florida
in a letter to employees disney
executive josh demaro explained that the
decision to relocate the jobs is partly
due to
florida's business friendly climate the
california policy center has documented
an extensive list of celebrities and
enterprises to leave the state due to
its high taxes and unfriendly business
climate this includes major corporations
like hewlett-packard
oracle palantir doll food nestle toyota
and many others moving thousands of jobs
out of california
notable celebrities and entrepreneurs
including elon musk joe and ben shapiro
have left the state in recent years as
well thoughts
it's just like everything else you know
it's a slow trickle of negativity in
california and
when this all first started five six
seven years ago when the country started
to get divided i thought you know no way
this is the united states we're gonna
rally i can't see this lasting forever
things are gonna turn but you know what
it's just like everything else a
celebrity here a company there
disney 2 000 employees here and i drop
around la right now pat
you won't even recognize it for what it
was when you moved to the united states
or even right before you left
it's the deterioration of everything
it's ugly okay there's no pride in
keeping up the city anymore there is
graffiti everywhere
there's garbage everywhere underneath
every bridge
bridge overhang there's there's just
tons of trash now the winnebagos are
lined up and you know everybody is sick
of the homeless issue
it's just gotten so out of control um
for me i'm going to myself okay what is
going to be the tipping point for me
and here's what it is i've decided i
think i know what it is for me
it's if antifa comes starting to do what
they did in portland
if they turn la into their next
battleground i will run from that state
very very very fast and i'm a little
worried because they've already had
a few little battles and things going on
in la already but
you know this is just another example
and you can't get more powerful than
disney sending out a statement that says
florida is business friendly i mean
every single word in that statement was
calculated and they were sending that
missile
and they'll send more they'll send more
this is the first wave of them going out
there but you know they have a little
issue in orlando because there's no
housing
so if they send two thousand people to
orlando there's very little inventory
for houses
they don't have enough new homes they
don't have enough housing for some
minutes out 40 miles out
and by the way traffic in orlando is
getting bad it's not it's not like you
used to be 10 years ago
so that that's the other situation that
we're dealing with but i mean look
that's a big deal 2 000 disney employees
moving to florida i really wouldn't
worry that much about it i think meet
kevin's going to organize the uh
national guard to come in and force
people to stay so there's that
it's going to be forced non-relocation
but friendly
friendly look forward to your seven
corny uh response videos to that one gov
but the uh but i gotta tell you man
i am not very happy about this because
these people are the parasites these
people are the parasite borg
from outer space who find they they
consume all the resources in an area and
then they they suck it dry with their
progressive policies
and they come to a new area that's ripe
without them
and they're going to suck it dry as well
you think disney is not going to bring
their progressive policies to florida
you think they're not going to bring
their financial influence into the
political system
they already have them here they've got
100 thousand employees already here two
thousand
two thousand five thousand relocate the
headquarters
listen let me let me and they may and it
may happen right but you have to also
sit there and ask the question why are
we leaving
why are we moving right why are we
leaving
look i i i still remember gilbane hojet
it's a street i was born on i still
remember jam hospital
it's the hospital i was born in i still
remember gulbenga
first five years i went to gulbengian it
was a scarmedian school
i still remember the assyrian church i
used to go to i still remember
remember going to esfan on vacation with
my family last the only vacation i
went on with my mom and dad i still
remember s-van i still remember going to
bandar pal levy
and driving by rashed which now they've
changed the name to the city and we'd go
down and have caviar
i still remember tamusiq hushang these
are all friends and family i still
remember
every one of these guys it's still in my
blood i am from iran
i love the culture that we had during
that time
armenian assyrian from iran till today
it's in my heart
every single time we think about iran we
ask
why do we leave i can say anything i was
silenced
we were afraid we were worried if you
told anybody you're christian if you
don't
and you would sit there like even as a
kid it didn't take a lot to realize
this concept didn't work freedom is
everything this is why we
go to america the greatest country in
the world till today i don't know what's
going to happen 10 years from now
but till today is the greatest country
in the world so a lot of these guys that
are leaving
here's what i'm wondering if you've ever
read the book by bob iger what's the
book called
the bob biker's book is the right of a
lifetime right
he talks about how he's sitting with uh
murdoch i think is in the book is he
sitting with murdoch and he's talking
about the fact murdock asks him so bob
any plans of running for office and
bob's like oh no i don't want to do
anything like that and he says in the
book i was thinking about it
but i couldn't tell him because what if
fox news goes out there and finds out
that i want to run what they would run
with it
i wanted to run and he wanted to run as
a what as a democrat
and governor wasn't he thinking right
away no no he wanted to go straight
to the presidency straight up to
presidency he's a democrat he talks
about why he's a democrat
he talked about why he's a democrat
because of his parents he's not a
democrat because he's a democrat he's a
democrat because he's loyal to his mom
and dad and it's a form of
undermining your family if you're a
democrat right i'd love to see some of
these guys who are democrats who are
leaving
california and going to florida not
telling you to be a republican
but it's time to become an independent
kind of say hey these policies you guys
are representing i just don't support
anymore what the hell is the matter with
you
are you seeing that though there's
empirical evidence in both arizona and
texas that they don't they
they relocate because those those
policies failed
and then they vote for those same
policies in their new location but i
think
bob deep down his side is a logical guy
i think the only reason a person
wouldn't is pride ego of saying you were
right
it's the only reason but we all
eventually get to a point where we sit
there and we think there was an idea
that we thought was good we're
eventually going to question it
i think some of the guys are going to
start converting so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you